if you're a fan of the witness or braid  you'll be interested in creator Jonathan  blows next game I'm Tony and this is  your prototype game spot news update  Jonathan Blow recently spoke at the  reboot Developers Conference where he  showed off a brief glimpse of his next  project the work-in-progress featured a  character on a grid pushing around  blocks but the art is far from finished  on top of this he mentioned that the  game's engine will be given away for  free to other developers the game itself  currently has quote 25 plus hours of  single-player gameplay but it's still  very much in its early stages but go  ahead and hit that subscribe button and  you'll be the first to know when more is  announced Jonathan blows most recent  project is the witness which received a  9 out of 10 from GameSpot and made it  onto our top games list of 2016 for a  look at one of our favourite games of  this year you can check out our persona  5 DLC showcase  [Music]  you